so this is the this is from Van Jones on
CNN the police who killed Tyree Nichols
were black but they might still have
been driven by racism it's just what
he's the same one at CNN he's the one
that occasionally you're like oh van
Jones said something I agree with you
right occasionally three decades ago
when four white LA police officers were
videotaped beating Rodney King the
public outcry was heard around the world
in fact I got arrested for the first
time in my life during protests that
followed and I subsequently dedicated my
career as a lawyer to helping to sue
Rogue cops closed prisons and reform the
criminal justice system
what happened to gang was horrifying he
then goes into mention but at least he
survived Tyree Nichols did not yada yada
five former Memphis police officers
fired for their elected actions during
Nichols versus a legend it was a video
of it have now been indicted I was in
law enforcement during the Rodney King
incidents as a chief by all accounts he
was good how do we explain Nichol's
horrific killing alleged the hands of
police who looked like him from the King
beating to the murder nearly three three
years ago of George Floyd blah blah blah
blah how do I explain it it's extract
people are not immune to anti-black
messages one of the sad facts about
anti-black racism is that black people
ourselves are not immune to its
pernicious effects at this point I just
want to give a round of applause to Van
Jones at for this sophistry at coming up
with a reason why these black cops were
actually anti-black racists for beating
up another black man it's not just him
though it's like Jameel uh Hill like
this was a common take on Twitter today
about this like as soon as they saw that
picture where all five cops are black
you're like well now we've got to go to
plan B like the original the original
plan was racism well like well now we're
gonna have to explain this a little more
what look what look what they did with
Zimmerman remember they were like a
white man it's like Zimmerman's Hispanic
I don't know if he's Mexican I think
Cuban there you go and they were like
well he's a white hispanic yeah what
does that mean are you kidding me what
I'm getting is Van Jones is suggesting
that these do these five cops were
serving the white master and doing its
bidding exactly but it's just so it's
not a white and black thing this is what
drives me nuts man yeah there are
corporate Overlord there are people with
power but I mean maybe maybe I'm blind
and that there really is a racial thing
like they they annihilated the Native
Americans they were like they're Savages
they didn't consider them human like
they were just killing anything that
wasn't white or whatever at the time
they had black slaves listen listen
listen there's a reason why these things
emerge in human civilization
you live in a small village of 100
people
everybody's Orange
you know that when you see a person and
they're orange you're like oh they
probably live in my Village I can I can
trust that and feel safe
100 miles away there's a village
everybody's green
one day you come across a green person
you're like that I've never seen that
person before I don't know who that is
they're not from my Village that's a
threat that's dangerous so over time as
humans are coming closer and closer
together we start living with people of
other with different backgrounds
different heights different skin colors
we start to go like oh you know that
didn't matter at all we we we're now
humans and so over time we start to
actually move away from this from from a
lot of this in the United States in a
bunch of other countries they don't so
you end up with yes race is often an
issue even in the United States people
racially profile even Mike Bloomberg
went on about how he does this and then
you end up with like I can understand to
a certain degree what van Jones is
saying but they're taking in a direction
that I think is disingenuous
there have been black cops who in on
numerous occasions have been seen
arresting and beating young black men
and then the woke activists try and
claim like oh the police did this and
it's white supremacy and it's racist and
then when you point out like hey I don't
think the race was the issue if the cops
themselves were black I think it's a
these guys are in a high crime
neighborhood they're black the people
who live there are black and the cops
are concerned about the level of crime I
don't think the black cop is looking at
the black kid and being like he looks
like me like what's he thinking
therefore this guy's more dangerous no I
think what it is is it doesn't matter if
you're white doesn't matter if you're
black it matters if they're like hey
we're sending you to a crime scene and
you're like okay
now you're going to be on edge and be
like I'm in a dangerous neighborhood I
think I feel like I mean what you're
saying makes me think of all of the
diversity and Equity recruit there are a
lot of police stations or
police departments across the country
that specifically where like we want to
make sure our Force represents the
people that they're policing right they
are of the same racial makeup they are
related to the community they have a
better way to relate to them like if I
don't know if Memphis has this policy in
place but if they do does this tell us
that like that doesn't matter that
people who are prone to be cruel and
violent will do it no matter who they're
looking at imagine if these guys were
like diversity hires like imagine that
like you know like like this is part of
the diversity equity and inclusion they
hire these guys but maybe I mean we I
remember there was a lawsuit I think was
that in New York where they purposefully
hire stupid people to be cops and they
said it's because they hire smart people
they get bored they quit and that that's
that's their excuse but you hire people
of low quality you're going to get low
quality output you know interesting do
you guys remember I I'm just totally
gonna bring this up do you remember when
Ben and Jerry's tweeted about this what
is it called the third the 1350
there are a bunch of people who they
were even posting this the other uh the
other day we were we were talking about
uh with Nuance bro crime in Democrat
cities and he mentioned the racial
disparity in crime and all that stuff
and I'm like I think there's a lot to do
with history poverty and then we look at
the surface level or I shouldn't say we
but a lot of people and they're like hey
I noticed a lot of crime in this
community and they tend to be this race
or that race and it's also like yeah but
there's a lot more context there that we
need to bring up I'm not saying race
plays no issue or anything I'm just
saying historical uh like slavery
generational wealth poverty lack of
Education these things play a much much
bigger role in my opinion than anything
else but Ben Jerry's this is a really
important point because the woke people
do this and that's exactly what this is
Ben and Jerry's posted on Twitter
something like
you know uh the African-American
Community is only 13 of the US
population but they comprise something
like you know 50 of prison inmates and
I'm like that's the same meme that
you'll see you know uh people post on
the internet that I don't want to say
every single person to post that is a
racist but are associated with being the
right or racist the left believes the
exact same thing yeah they they the left
want segregation
the left is blaming racism
anti-blackness on why black cops
attacked a black man because they can't
help but view the entire world through
the lens of race
it's it's the woke law of projection you
have a white liberal who is extremely
racist who then says you know what
you're racist too and you're like me I'm
not racist and like yes you are the
reason they're saying that is because
they think everyone must think the same
thing they do they can't imagine that
other people have different beliefs it's
a cult so
everybody projects everybody thinks the
way I view the world is the way everyone
else views the world no I shouldn't say
everybody it's a lot of people who
understand that they don't probably tend
to watch shows like this or Crowder or
six exam or even bars like to be on the
opposite side of the wokeness but these
woke people very much so are racist
and then project thinking if I think
this way so must everyone else then they
go to you and tell you you're racist and
no matter what you say they won't
believe you because you must think well
if you don't that's why fragility
exactly that's literally what that book
is based on so you end up with Van Jones
writing the only explanation as to why
five black men wait another black man
was because of white supremacy when it's
just like maybe it's because they're
cops maybe it's because they have a
short fuse because of the things they
witness all day every day and they were
angry and it's nothing to do with the
race of these men because they were all
black I'm sick of everything having to
be someone's race like look I'll put it
this way sometimes it is race sometimes
it is a white cop hating a black person
sometimes it's a black cop hating an
Asian person who knows I'm just saying
it annoys me that woke people especially
but you know others as well immediately
assume the cause of and the correlation
is well it was the race and I'm like
dude come on man yeah for all we know
this guy was banging dude's wife well
Jamil Hill said the silent part out loud
this is what she said what you were
saying about the police I need I need so
many people to understand this regarding
uh Tyree Nichols several of the police
officers who murdered Freddie gray were
black the entire system of policing is
based on white supremacist violence
like it's it's trying to she's saying
get rid of the police I'm just I'm just
it's amazing it's someone walking up to
you and saying listen the sky is is pink
and you go I'm looking up and the sky is
blue actually that's because you've got
a a lens Distortion perspective and that
proves actually this guy is pink no I
can see it dude when you when when you
come out and you say did you know that
the cops who killed Freddie gray some of
them were also black I'm like so that
basically disproves your whole narrative
no it actually proves it
they can't lose
I I'd love to uh I wish I had that kind
of societal power to say something that
proves the opposite proves the opposite
just be at a casino and it's like
you know I was like hit me 25. actually
they changed the rules Jacks are now
oh you have 21. I keep winning it
reminds me wasn't there a movie where a
guy was like the only one in the world
who knew how to lie yeah yeah I like
that movie a lot I've never seen it
what's that one Invention of Lying yeah
so he's he's broke so it's a world where
no one can lie and then he's broke he
can't pay his rent he's gonna get
evicted and then he goes to the bank and
then it like shout like he's like I need
to withdraw money and they're like I'm
sorry you don't have you you only have a
certain amount of money in your bank
account then it zooms into his brain and
shows like a noron fire and then he goes
no I have 800 on my account and she goes
that's strange it doesn't say that must
be a mistake okay I'll withdraw that
money for you because there's no lying
so it's like and then she gives him the
money and he's like whoa and then he
basically becomes like king of the world
because he can move he's funny he's
funny I think it's a great movie it's
like it's like a movie that makes you
think kind of but it is funny movies in
this universe are people sitting in
chairs reading history yeah there's no
fiction so then he starts writing
fiction and people are like watching
these movies all excited thinking it's
real it's kind of like uh like
historically like through the eons that
the the lying deceitful one monkey or
whoever in the in the culture of our
great ancestors were like the ones that
were able to weasel their way into Power
by by hiding the food so that the other
ones couldn't find their food and
they're like where's our food then they
starve and he's like hahaha and so it's
in our genetics that you need to deceive
to get into power but what we want is an
honest leader but you need a strong
Society to support an honest leader or
the leader will just be taken advantage
of and destroyed by evil and subterfuge
it's so easy to burn down what's what's
functional but it's so challenging to
create it to build it yeah so I think
we're on a path to create an honest
leader right now it seems like think
about building a machine and all of the
fine parts that go in it and then
someone can just take a piece of bubble
gum and start right in the whole machine
breaks and then you're like I can't get
that bubble gum out something that's so
stupid and easy to make some bubble gum
some tree sap some rubber destroys you
know 50 years of your work think about
how you could gum up a car think about
how you could pour sugar or some other
garbage into the tank it's like so easy
to tear a machine down it's so hard to
build it and it's easy to lie about
machines when they're not functioning
because like it can cause Panic if
you're honest about the the mishaps and
the dangers of society people can free
if you don't understand the danger but
you're honest about it that's scary like
hey there's a problem I don't have a
solution for and that can cause Panic
which can cause the dissolution of the
system so you're better off historically
lying about it and being everything's
fine close your eyes everything's fine
and if it burns it burns you know
there's no one there to come after me
for lying but but I I think now you know
well one we have the the tools like the
internet where we can solve these
problems climate change you know we can
withdraw the carbon turn it into
graphene we can regrow the plankton in
the ocean by with iron fertilization we
can regrow the coral reefs with uh
cultural micro fragmentation of coral
where you're breaking into a bunch of
pieces and it all grows at once together
you can we can build space elevators and
Elevate you know we can colonize but
there are solutions but it's a matter of
organizing them and communicating them
calmly and I think if if we can do that
we won't need to lie to each other well
and everyone has to agree that like
those things are worth doing right like
if you have a small group of people and
they collectively have the same values
and they're like yep we pick him to be
the leader and he's our best interest
you know it's easier but when you talk
about large-scale issues that everyone
has a different role in right like this
comes up with uh you know global warming
all the time will this company this
country is really trying hard to reduce
all of its emissions but this country
doesn't care about it they don't
prioritize it and they are actually
emitting more carbon into the atmosphere
like at what point do we get people to
work on that because they actually have
their own self-interest for their own
communities I just want to go back to
this van Jones thing real quick and just
say just dupe to pause real quick and
just entertain this thought
we we had someone in the chat say I
heard that Tyree Nichols was banging
some dude's wife and we're like whoa I
mean you know we're wondering if there
was something personal here but we can't
verify that CNN's running a story being
like Oh actually the cops were white
supremacists it's like the first one's
more believable this is the point I said
we're the mainstream media so it's like
if you came to me and said here's a
video of a man wailing on the face of
another man I'd be like damn what do you
do bang the guy's wife because it is a
simple solution to assume they had a
beef but then imagine a news anchor says
actually we think the real reason is
that that black man swinging his fists
is actually a white supremacist so it's
like okay so you want me to believe
CNN van Jones that those five black men
were anti-black racists with
internalized white supremacy as a more
plausible reason as opposed to homeboy
bang dude's wife Dave Chappelle did the
skit that's basically Clayton Bigsby but
he couldn't even pull it off he had to
make the guy blind you can't just he
couldn't be like if you saw his own skin
color you know then the joke it wouldn't
even be funny you know you to believe
that like racism and internal race it's
like it's more deadly than covet you
know it's like literally the most
dangerous thing out there that infects
your mind and it can take a black person
and make them actually hate black people
and do something that this is what
they're saying with a straight face
which is amazing but I will say racism
is is disgusting when you talk to
someone that actually is really racist
and they say it and you're like what
what are you it's gross but the thing is
Van Jones is softening it and making it
so you don't he's racist well and I'd
say one further like he wrote this for
CNN it has the opinion label on it right
but then someone else at CNN is going to
say here are some factual reporting and
some people believe it was actually
motivated by white supremacy and they'll
link to his article but then it'll
continue to be cycled and cycled and
cycled until it becomes part of the
normal narratives it's these cops who
were motivated by white paternity beat
this guy like it's it's a kind of nasty
cycle of absorbing these these guesses
at what's going on I agree it's gross
for me I would phrase it as racism is
annoying
on at an academic level and it's gross
on a personal level like we've we have a
bunch of friends of the show who are a
variety of different races and just
thinking about the fact that like a
racist person would say something
negative about any of the guests we've
had on who are not white I mean these
are good people you know these are
people of good opinion we have people
like uh the hoteps come on we have
people like Andy no I know you mentioned
earlier on but with people about
different backgrounds and I'm like these
are all people who are good people that
that do good work that agree with a lot
of your opinions and then you'd have
someone who just says because the way
they look I have a negative view I'm
like Ah that's the stupidest thing but
but the reason it's annoying to me is
that when you look at a situation like
this with Tyree Nichols we're asking
ourselves what is the context and
Circumstance that results in a con in a
conflict like this it is not because the
men internalized white supremacy that
makes literally no sense it's a strange
crackpot conspiracy theory
but it's annoying to me because I'm like
yo I'm trying to solve a problem here
and it's like you're coming out it's
it's like watching someone with a
Chinese finger trap pull as hard as they
can and you're like my guy just stop
okay it's not the surface level Solution
on this one sometimes maybe you could
probably pull so hard you'll rip the
thing apart
but we're trying to figure out why this
happened and I don't think it's because
Tyree Nichols was banging into his wife
but that certainly makes more sense it
could simply be because the cops are
frustrated and angry maybe something
happened earlier in the day maybe Tyree
was they said it was reckless driving
some people are disputing that we have
no idea but when van Jones comes out and
says oh it's because they were racist
it's like bro we're not going to solve
the problem of what's happening with bad
cops like this I'm not saying all cops
when there are bad cops if you just say
racism it's like okay actually that cop
was doing illegal deals in bribery you
know if we're gonna actually hold it
hold them accountable we need to hold
them accountable for the things that are
leading to this not just ah racism it's
the racism industrial complex if racism
disappeared tomorrow think of how many
people would be unemployed our economy
every Democrat every non-profit would
just go kaput there would be no need for
half of them uh how many politicians
would lose their jobs like I'm on
Twitter today and I'm seeing like when I
see Kamala Harris and uh and Joe Biden
talking about this guy I don't know it
just really angered me about the
situation Duxbury Mass where they will
never mention those three innocent
children who they will never mention
them but they will make make it seem
like this guy this is the biggest deal
in the world because racism is the
biggest problem confronting our country
why would they want a cure for it when
they can just keep selling the antidote
and keep getting elected off let's
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time